a musical at the theater a christmas
tradition for many but from tomorrow
audiences at manchester's palace theatre
and entertainment venues all over
england will need a covet pass to watch
the show people here don't seem to mind
however
i'd rather protect other people myself
in all honesty and if we all just follow
it it's gonna be
a lot easier in the long run i think if
the system is right
then it shouldn't be a pain i think
it'll make queues long as well i think
it'll take a long time to get into
venues now
but at westminster conservative mps are
threatening a major rebellion in votes
on boris johnson's plan b coveted
restrictions with the rebels bitterly
opposed to covet passes i think they are
further erosion of civil liberties i
think they're deeply damaging to our
economy and also i think it's a further
distraction from those other health
conditions that the pandemic has already
distracted us from
the rebellion could be bigger than the
prime minister's 80-seat commons
majority
today's votes on these new coveted
regulations which run to 24 pages are
likely to see boris johnson suffer the
biggest tory rebellion since the general
election two years ago
the previous record was 54 rebels that
was on the tier system of coveted
restrictions but today's revolt is
likely to be much bigger
it's never been part of our ethos in the
united kingdom to compel people by law
to become immunized uh with the threat
of a criminal sanction if you don't and
i think that we've got to be very
careful we don't set precedents
that are making people in the country
criminals in these areas when it's
really a public health issue
after the government warned that the new
omicron variant is currently infecting
200 000 people a day across the uk
the pm is today appealing for a
volunteer army to sign up to help
deliver his target of a million booster
jabs a day with 24-hour vaccination
centers and jabs on christmas day
planned
and with the pm refusing to rule out
further covert restrictions
many tory mps fear that if plan b is
approved today before long the
government may introduce a plan c
john craig sky news